Good morning.
We'll now start.
We're still in the first test,
and we'll now start on Section
9 on page 423.
So let's start with
the first problem.
Problem number 1.
If 5t equals 45, and tk is
equal to 1, what is k?
Well, 5t equals 45.
This is an easy equation.
You divide both sides by
5, you get t equals 9.
And then you have tk equals 1.
We know what t is equal to.
t is equal to 9, right?
So we get 9k is equal to 1.
Divide both sides by 9, you
get k is equal to 1/9.
And that is choice B.
That's pretty straightforward.
All right.
Number 2.
I'll switch colors.
It takes 4 complete rotations
of-- it's
early in the morning.
I can't even read properly.
It takes 4 complete turns
of a crank to
raise a window 2 inches.
So 4 turns raise the
window 2 inches.
At this rate, how many turns
does it take to raise the same
window 3 and 1/2 inches?
OK.
So 4 turns, 2 inches.
Just to simplify things, we
could say, well, that's the
same thing as 2 turns
per inch.
Right?
2 turns per inch, or you could
even say 1 turn per 1/2 inch.
But let's just say
2 turns per inch.
I just divided the top by 2.
If 4 turns to do 2 inches,
it's going to take 2
turns to do 1 inch.
And it wants to know, the same
window, 3 and 1/2 inches.
Actually, when I first
read it, I read it
as 3 and 1/2 feet.
So actually, this isn't that.
So we want to go 3
and 1/2 inches.
It's early in the morning.
My brain is still foggy.
We could actually even
ignore this.
So we can just set this
up as a ratio.
4 turns goes 2 inches,
is equal to x
turns for 3 and 1/2.
And 3 and 1/2, we could write
that as 3.5, or we could write
that as 7/2.
And then we cross multiply.
So 4 times 7/2 is equal to 2x.
And then this cancels
with this.
We have 14 is equal to 2x.
x is equal to 7 turns.
And that's choice B.
Sorry for leading you in
the wrong direction.
I thought they said 3 and
1/2 feet at first. OK.
Turn the page.
Number 3.
Image here.
I'll switch colors again.
Keeps it interesting for
me, at least. OK.
If x/y is equal to 2/3, what
is the value of 3x/2y?
So we know this, and how do
we get the value of this?
Well, we could just manipulate
this relationship
algebraically.
So we have 3x/2y on the
left-hand side, and then
whatever we end up on the
right-hand side is our answer.
So let's see how you do that.
So we start off with x/y
is equal to 2/3.
Well, to get here, let's
multiply both sides by 3.
So if you do a 3 over here,
we have to also multiply
this side by 3.
And then if we multiply both
sides by 1/2-- because this 2
in the denominator is
essentially 1/2-- then you end
up with a 2 here,
and a 2 here.
So now we have 3x and 2y.
And now we have 2
times 3 is 6.
3 times 2 is 6.
That equals 1.
Choice C.
All right.
The next one looks like I
have to do some drawing.
So let me clear this
out a little bit.
Number 4.
In the figure above-- let me
draw the figure above.
Looks complicated, huh?
So I have one line that goes
straight like this.
I have one line that goes
straight up like this.
I have another line that crosses
that line like that.
And then I got a bunch
of points.
Let me draw the points.
It takes more time to draw these
than to maybe do them,
although I haven't done
this, so I don't know.
Maybe it will take time.
N.
This is P.
This is T, and R, S.
Then I have O.
Then I've got the angle.
They're calling this angle y,
calling this y degrees.
They say this angle here
is 20 degrees.
And they say this is
a right angle.
And they say that this angle
right here is x degrees.
All right.
So let's read what they're
saying now.
In the figure above, PS--
so this is PS-- and TR
intersect at O.
Right.
We drew that.
ON is perpendicular to PS.
This is my little perpendicular
signal,
looks like an r.
OK.
That's perpendicular.
What is the value
of y minus x?
Interesting.
So let me ask you a question.
y is the opposite
angle to what?
If you remember from the
geometry, opposite angles are
equivalent, right?
If I have two lines that
intersect like this, then this
angle is going to be equal
to this angle.
So we know this is y, so what
angle is opposite y?
Well, this angle
is opposite y.
This whole thing.
So what is this angle?
This angle is x degrees plus
this 90 degrees, right?
It's x plus 90.
That's this whole angle.
I added this part of
it plus this part.
That equals this whole angle,
and it's the same thing as y.
And they draw the stuff to
really confuse you, wrote 20
degrees here.
None of that really matters.
So y is going to be equal to
this whole angle, and that
whole angle is going to be equal
to this 90 degrees-- is
equal to this part plus
this part-- plus x.
Subtract x from both sides,
you get y minus
x is equal to 90.
That's it.
That was number 4.
That's choice C.
I do all that and the problem
took too little time.
OK.
Image.
Invert.
OK, so here they've
got a schedule.
It's the schedule above,
and hopefully you
have your book open.
I'm on page 424.
In the schedule above, each
session is to be 1 and 1/2
hours long.
Each break is to be 1/4 hour
long, and lunch is
to be 1 hour long.
All right.
Session-- oh, boy.
I should just draw this thing.
Maybe it'll run into the-- no,
I didn't want to do that.
This is my chart.
Three columns.
I've got this one, and
I've got this one.
And then I'm going to have one,
two, three, four, five,
six, seven.
I'm going to run out of space.
Trying to make this too neat.
I don't know if I ran
out of space or not.
I'll probably have to continue
this in the next video, but
I'll just keep drawing until
the time runs out.
In the next video, it'll
be all set up.
So this is the event,
begin time, end.
Actually, I'll just continue
this in the next video.
I don't want to waste your
time drawing this.
I'll draw it, and then
we'll start the next
video on this problem.
See you soon.